doordash story let's go to the doordash
story here all right page three uh Uncle
Tom is uh very excited today which is
fantastic all right every doordash
employee from Engineers to CEO will make
deliveries this is a CNN story doordash
is asking its employees all the way up
the ranks to its Co to make a delivery
at least once a month some are not
cheering the news the on-demand food
delivery company in New Year will
reinstate a program called we Dash that
it has paused during the pandemic as a
company grew the founder wanted everyone
to experience different parts of the
product so we could get closer to our
audiences and understand how the product
works a doordash employee comes back
who's making 400 000 to complain about a
company-wide an initiative requiring
that he personally make one delivery a
month this is an Insider story
doordash making Engineers uh deliver a
mandatory we Dash starts next year we
need to dash once a month we will be
tracked in performance reviews what the
actual F I didn't sign up for this
there's was nothing in the offer letter
job description about this I'm
delivering well I mean obviously that
guy right there is a definitely a
believer of doordash and what they do
but what do you think about the story
here how much you want to bet that guy
went to an Ivy League school
agree with you I actually absolutely
love this idea there's nothing worse
than uh higher up corporate bureaucrat
whatever you want to call it who's
completely out of touch
um I completely agree completely agree
you know there's to be a man of the
people to understand your product they
use the word specifically closer to our
audience this is exactly the purpose of
why they're actually doing this I assume
though Tom so you understand what it's
like to deliver and be a driver and deal
with the traffic and deal with an angry
customer like to put yourself in the
average worker's shoes how do you have
this one guy who's making 400 is too
cool for school to do a delivery a month
bro get a life
I completely agree you know it's
interesting and the first company that
got involved with Pat he he evangelized
me into it and I thought it was great
and what I did and he knows this when I
was in Ubers in an Uber I would talk to
the Uber driver and I would find out
people that were looking to do a little
bit more looking to do things and I
recruited not one not two but three that
I passed off to agents or at the company
and I thought Uber drivers well yeah but
but the point is I ran into people and
Uber happened to be the situation and I
said hey check out PHP look at the
opportunity you could have here if
you're looking for making a little extra
money this is a way to do it also
serving a market so I came to appreciate
at that moment exactly what every one of
our agent does when they're when they
were working with it of course so I
think this is good to be out on the
front I'm a product that is Jaime godina
who worked at Galpin Ford it's 2002 he
sold me a Ford Focus stayed up to 11 30
to sell me a Ford Focus payment was 228
a month I was so broke I lost my
Expedition I couldn't pay the payment
saying well I'm at the lowest point in
my life in O2 years later I said when I
was sitting with them he told me I said
what what what what car should I buy he
says well uh what do you want to get I
said what do you have he said a great
question let me show you the cards that
I have I have this I have this I have
this it was all four products
I love the fact that a guy who owns the
products is selling it to me I I have a
hard time if you're selling Mercedes
you're driving a BMW yeah like when Eli
Manning was doing the commercials for
Toyota Corolla and I was like get out of
here
yeah hops in a G wagon goes home yeah so
so the point is there's a drive to
Toyota to my G-Wagon there's a part of
this that I like and guess what this
does the guy who's running doordash just
realized who doesn't really believe in
the concept of what they do as a company
and it was too much of a high you know
corporate executive that's not going to
get their hands too dirty to go out
there and say you know what maybe this
is what I got to do to understand what
everybody else does it helps to get
closer to your uh to the folks that are
also working my question is who would
think this is a bad idea other than this
engineer who's probably just wants to
sit in front of a computer all day maybe
he's baked or not cookies of course
why would why is this a bad idea play
devil's advocate here this is not a bad
idea exactly I can't even think about it
by the way I'm saying I can't
I've been in many meetings where you
launched an initiative and all of a
sudden you know who's in and who's not
right it's a filtering process and I
love the fact that doordash announced
this did he push a little harder it'll
open up go a little lower and push it
harder it'll open up a little lower
there you go let me tell you man that
this actually annoys me so much like I
don't even want to use doordash like
this one guy being too good for it but
but don't let that happen because the
CEO is doing the right I look at it the
opposite way actually this is on my
radar
I actually have more respect for it
doordash now totally I like the fact
that the seal and the founder thought
about this idea so if you enjoy this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]